se succèdent depuis la visite du Premier
ministre ukrainien le 11 avril touchant
hier le site web de Justin Trudeau et ce
matin l'Office des transports du Canada
tout comme celui du port de Montréal
inaccessible pendant une heure mais sans
conséquence grave en aucun temps nos
systèmes et nos opérations n'ont été
affectées et toutes les informations et
les données n'ont pas été touchées
indiquons dans une déclaration encore
des cyberattaques de type déni de
service mené par le groupe nomame
davantage un dérangement qu'autre chose
c'est vraiment
de la vitrine c'est comme un impact
d'ensemble maternel c'est Julien super
sérieux par contre qui inquiète
plusieurs dont moi le c'est est-ce que
ça pourrait mener à quelque chose de
plus gros parce qu'on est en train de
sonder le terrain le voir qui qui est
bien protégé qu'il l'est pas il existe
justement des logiciels peu coûteux
capables de détecter des attaques de
type déni service mais l'adoption de
bonnes habitudes est essentielles de
faire ses mises à jour on sait que 61%
des cyber-attaques qui réussissent son
compte des vulnérabilités qui ont déjà
été adressées par le manufacturier une
cyberata qu'aurait aussi touché les
pages jaunes revendiquées par le groupe
de pirates black basta on parle ici
d'une tentative d'extorsion par rançon
judiciaire les motivations seraient
économiques plutôt que politique
des informations encore là on a vu des
échantillons de passeport de carte
d'assurance maladie des rapports de
dépenses des cyberattaques applis à se
poursuivre avec un conflit en Ukraine
qui ne semble pas sur le point de se
terminer ici aimez le mieux Radio-Canada
Montréal